[Music]
on this Tuesday night reopening Europe's
borders and restarting tourism Canada
makes the list of safe countries and the
u.s. does not concern about travel we're
cleared for takeoff but should we go
increasing alarm about how many people
could die of Kovach 19 in the US it is
going to be very disturbing I will
guarantee you that and multiplying
demands for a coherent strategy
Toronto's mission to make wearing face
masks mandatory and showcasing the scope
of Canada's diversity
[Music]
a sharp new rendition of our National
Anthem
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
after months of enduring this pandemic
some people are dreaming of a vacation
abroad and today the European Union
desperate to save its lucrative summer
tourist season is making a big push to
reel us in the EU has released a list of
countries it considers safe and Canada
is one of 14 countries that made the cut
the United States did not Airlines are
also getting anxious to get more people
on board they're relaxing physical
distancing policies and planning to fly
full flights Canadian public health
experts though are sending a different
message they say just because you can
doesn't mean you should and even if you
do fly abroad you must self isolate for
14 days when you come home airlines are
facing accusations of putting profit
ahead of public health and Canadians are
caught in the middle trying to figure
out what's really safe this summer our
coverage begins with crystal commencing
in the --use attempt to save its tourism
season after months of sitting empty
Terminal 3 at the main International
Airport in Rome is expected to spring
back to life the Missy DiMaggio passage
Edison was led on this week says the
airport director general we had an
average of about 13,000 passengers per
day usually we would have 150,000
passengers per day we are expecting
further increases with the gradual
reopening I think with such a tamanna'
being a factor
starting July 1st foreign tourists from
more than a dozen countries including
Canada are being welcomed back to Europe
vote I recommend a feeling he'll be a
cupid meeting land Spain will adopt the
European recommendation says the
government's spokesperson
which will allow the entrance of
travelers from third countries the
pandemic had a stranglehold on Europe
cutting off the tourism sector which
generates 400 billion euros or more than
six hundred ten billion Canadian
annually health experts however worry
the invite could lead to a surge in
cases
concerned about the attitudes I see
taken by Airlines particularly their
advertising
I see Airlines offering flight people
all over the place to hurting in July
the EU may have wanted reciprocal travel
agreements but Canada has extended its
ban on most foreign travelers until at
least July 31st New Zealand is also on
the EU list of safe countries but it
says it's not prepared to risk exporting
or importing cases for the sake of a
holiday I do think it is dangerous to
suggest that we open up our borders at
this point in time this pandemic
globally is growing Christel commencing
Global News London airlines are among
the industry's hardest hit by the
pandemic and they're anxious to start
packing planes with passengers again
starting tomorrow
Air Canada in WestJet will no longer
keep the middle seats open to allow for
physical distancing on board airlines
say the decision is based on
recommendations from the International
Air Transport Association that a
Canadian passenger rights advocate says
airlines should instead be listening to
the advice of public health experts who
say it's too soon
the airlines are trying to make more
profit they seem to be getting more
demand so they think that they can now
do something with us middle seats but in
practice they seem to be playing Russian
roulette with passengers lives British
Columbia's Health Minister too is
questioning the move he wants federal
officials to provide evidence that
relaxing physical distancing on flights
is safe what I like to hear from Health
Canada is do they agree with this
because it is absolutely within their
jurisdiction to deal with so if what
they're saying is what air can and wish
to do he's acceptable to them they need
to be explicit and they need to explain
why it is and that's what we'll be
waiting to hear earlier this year
Transport Canada recommended that
Airlines provide physical distancing on
planes when possible the agency though
did not make it mandatory there are more
signs how much the collapse in travel is
affecting Air Canada after laying off
20,000 employees the company now says
it's suspending service on 30 domestic
routes indefinitely most are in Ontario
Quebec and
to Canada the company also says it's
shutting down operations at eight
regional airports Air Canada reported a
net loss of more than a billion dollars
in the first quarter of 2020 because of
the pandemic if you do fly most airlines
require you wear a mask on board
Transport Canada has made it mandatory
at airports and on planes where you
can't keep physically distant from other
people the advice about mask wearing
though has shifted through the course of
this pandemic the consensus now is
wearing a non-medical mask in public can
help reduce the spread of the new corona
virus and the debate now is more about
whether to encourage mask wearing or
make it mandatory mic relay explains
Toronto's mayor arrived with a prompt a
mask taking it off to announce
Torontonians you should be putting them
on we're gonna rely largely on education
and public awareness council voted to
make mass mandatory for indoor public
settings and businesses starting next
week across the Greater Toronto Area
which would coincide with the start of a
similar mandate for transit riders
across Ontario
John Tory's by law comes after a premier
Doug Ford dismissed the idea of a
province-wide mask roll saying it's
unenforceable wear the mask it's I think
it's critical that you do that
but the police 14.5 million people would
be very very difficult it won't be any
easier in Toronto where Tory hopes
people simply do the right thing
there won't really be an aggressive
enforcement to be candid about it in
Quebec transit riders who refuse to wear
masks won't be fined the beginning July
27th they'll be denied entry the rule
will be that the only consequence will
be that you cannot use the transport
there's no fine the mask role has worked
at reducing kovat cases in other locales
particularly New York City and Italy
outside the risk of transmission is very
much reduced unless there's a lot of
people in a close proximity to each
other but indoors the risk of
transmission is much higher and
especially in a situation
we're physical distancing is not as easy
in British Columbia we're case numbers
have been quite low the provincial
health officer recommends masks but will
not make it mandatory and over the last
three weeks there has been one day where
the number of daily cases across all of
Canada rose over 400 anti masters will
no doubt seize on that fact which could
lead to confrontations like this
well Torontonians comply or will the
Health versus freedom debate ignite
north of the border as well micro like
Global News Toronto I can't make an
accurate prediction but it is going to
be very disturbing I will guarantee you
that because when you have an outbreak
in one part of the country even though
in other parts of the country they're
doing well they are vulnerable that's
America's top infectious disease expert
dr. Anthony Fauci testifying today about
how bad things could get in the US the
numbers are surging so fast experts
aren't even giving a revised estimate on
how many people might die cases are on
the rise in more than half of all states
I see yous are filling up and as Jackson
prosecco reports the country is divided
over what to do
removing any doubt about the grim
trajectory of the pandemic America's top
disease experts warn the u.s. is no
longer able to rein in the virus clearly
we are not in total control right now
case numbers are surging at an
incredible rate especially in four
heavily populated states ICU beds are
running short in Arizona and in Texas
where protesters objected to a new
statewide order to reclose bars
[Applause]
seventeen states have paused or scrapped
reopening as new infections soar to more
than 40,000 per day across the country I
would not be surprised if we go up to a
hundred thousand a day if this does not
turn around the majority of states are
now seeing some sort of increase risking
the progress made in places like New
York the first to be hard-hit we can't
just focus on those areas that are
having the surge it puts the entire
country at
risk in a country already divided over
how to respond the director of the
Centers for Disease Control called for
universal adoption of masks advice
regularly undermined by President Trump
and his supporters it is critical that
we all take the personal responsibility
to slow the transmission of COBIT 19 and
embrace the universal use of face
coverings and in a preview of the
election to come Democratic presidential
nominee Joe Biden called out what he
says is a failure of leadership at a
time of unprecedented national crisis we
need a president mr. president a
president level of the American people
president tell us the earned varnish
truth even optimism about a vaccine is
beginning to wane amongst the experts
over fears that too many Americans will
refuse one if it is successfully
developed that would prevent this
country from achieving herd immunity
allowing the virus to continue its
widespread Donna Jackson Prosecco in
Washington thank you there's revealing
new data about so-called silent
spreaders people who have an active case
of Kovach 19 but have no symptoms it's
based on a small town where the first
Cove in nineteen death was recorded in
Italy and which successfully suppressed
its spread the research published in the
journal Nature is from the town of Voe
population 3200 where a man died of
Kovac 19 On February 21st the town
immediately went into a two-week
lockdown and nearly every resident was
tested and then quarantined if their
results were positive deeper analysis
found more than 40% of people who tested
positive showed no signs of sickness
researchers also found asymptomatic
carriers had a similar viral load to
those who did have symptoms suggesting
so-called silent spreaders can
significantly contribute to the spread
of the disease the study's authors argue
widespread testing isolating all
infected people not just those with
symptoms and a community lockdown
effectively stopped the outbreak in its
tracks a strain of swine flu in China is
generating lots of scary headlines a
little later in the news
gasps we'll go beyond those headlines
and explain what the experts are looking
at more and more companies are
boycotting Facebook Ford coca-cola and
Starbucks are among the latest big
brands to pull paid ads from Facebook
though only for the month of July
some Canadian companies have also joined
what's called a stop hate for-profit
campaign they say the social media giant
isn't doing enough to keep hateful and
misleading content off its platform
Facebook does have massive reach and
political parties and the federal
government rely on it too our chief
political correspondent David akin has
been looking into whether they have any
plans to join the Facebook boycott David
yeah well unlike corporations political
parties advocacy groups they find social
media and Facebook in particular to be
an absolutely indispensable tool when it
comes to motivating partisans raising
money and finding volunteers and data
supplied by Facebook itself shows how
active Canada's major political
organizations are on the platform
the Liberals spent 2.3 million dollars
on Facebook ads in the last year the
Conservatives spent 1.6 million and the
NDP spent four hundred and sixty three
thousand all but the NDP are running ads
right now on the platform
indeed for most political contests these
days from a local nomination race to the
current Conservative Party leadership
fight the campaigning takes place almost
exclusively on social media and Facebook
says it is responding to criticism in a
statement to Global News a spokesperson
noted that it did ban former Toronto
mayoral candidate faith Goldie and
others from its platform for violating
hate speech policies and this week
Facebook said it would subject itself to
a civil rights on it now as vital as
these online tools are for politicians
and peace have not been afraid to
criticize these platforms in fact and
peace from all parties have been
pressing social media platforms and
Facebook to do more to fight hate speech
done David what about the federal
government itself it's a major
advertiser and social media networks is
it reviewing its policy
well it is a major advertiser the
federal government spends about five and
a half million dollars a year on
Facebook but let's put this in
perspective Facebook earns seventy
billion dollars a year from advertisers
around the world so that's really not
much when you look at what the federal
government spends we ask the prime
minister's office if the federal
government was prepared to join this
boycott they did not respond to our
questions what we can tell you there is
no advertising review underway right now
done all right David akin in Ottawa
thanks in New York City Mayor Bill de
Blasio is reallocating one billion
dollars from that city's police
department to summer youth programming
social services and public housing
critics say the changes could put public
safety at risk others say it's about
time and that more money needs to be
shifted away from police to social
services carl reiner left a big imprint
on our popular culture they thought knew
that I was Erie kill me coming up a
glimpse at the comedy giant's incredible
career
one of Hollywood's comedy greats Carl
Reiner has passed away a weak stomach
mr. zerga
I don't believe in weakness it costs too
much his career spanned more than 60
years and he was a master of his craft
in front of the camera and behind it
he'll be remembered for his
collaborations with Mel Brooks in the
1950s and 60s and creating what he
called his favorite the Dick Van Dyke
Show he directed the classic Steve
Martin films the jerk and all of me and
Reiner never called it quits he was
working well into his 90s last year he
lent his voice to the hit movie Toy
Story for Kriner and his late wife had
three children including actor and
director Rob Reiner Carl Reiner died at
home it was 98 years old still ahead why
experts say a new flu linked to pigs
shouldn't make fears fly
[Applause]
demonstrators in Hong Kong voice their
anger today over China's new national
security law they fear it will tighten
Beijing's grip on the semi-autonomous
region and lead to a greater crackdown
on dissent the law will allow Beijing to
take over in a crisis such as last
year's pro-democracy protests some
offences will carry a punishment of life
in prison
the law passed one day before the 23rd
anniversary of Britain handing over
control of Hong Kong back to China well
as if we don't have enough to be worried
about now there are scary headlines
about another strain of influenza found
in pigs in China some workers on pig
farms have become infected with it but
not become sick and there's no evidence
of human-to-human transmission so right
now there's not much to back up those
scary headlines as Redman Shannon
explains the h1n1 flu pandemic in 2009
likely killed tens of thousands of
people worldwide it was nowhere near as
deadly as covered 19 partly because
older people tended to be immune to it
but this newer strain of so-called swine
flu is something experts are taking note
of precisely because it is new it's not
so called an immediate threat where
you're seeing infections but it's
something we need to keep our eye out on
just the way we did in 2009 the Chinese
researchers took samples from 30,000
pigs over seven years they found a new
g4 strain of h1n1 emerge in 2013 it can
be passed from pigs to humans but
probably not between humans about 10% of
slaughterhouse workers had antibodies
indicating they were exposed to people
tested positive one of whom died this is
something that we need to be aware and
we need to be working for them but
people shouldn't be freaking out things
professor Scott wheeze says experts will
be tracking how the strain evolves right
now if you've got something that doesn't
spread well person-to-person it doesn't
have as big a population relevance but
if this virus can change by itself or
get together with another
then we've got more concerns if the
virus does start spreading between
humans developing a vaccine should be
relatively easy down to decades of
worldwide experience in tackling the flu
Redman Shannon Global News London
singing through reckoning next a Calgary
choir tunes into where Canada has fallen
short
[Music]
on the eve of Canada Day at a time when
we're confronting some hard truths about
racism Canada's Minister of diversity
and inclusion has a message for the
country we have been reminded that
Canada is not immune to the realities of
systemic racism inequality and racial
injustice it never was
it is a part of our history that's
something many of us have been thinking
about including a choir group in Calgary
as Heather Eurex West explains they're
releasing a special version of Oh Canada
[Music]
Calgary chorister akina has always
thought of Oh Canada as a prayer instead
of like talking about Fiji to them and
and Canada itself it's less than the
land and banking
Makena has been singing the anthem
increase since she was 12 years old the
translation was a gift to her from an
elder
kid
mark in Canada today in a moment of
reckoning with issues of racism and
reconciliation when a pandemic continues
to keep us apart isn't exactly an easy
thing but it's something the team at
Calgary's rev 52 tried to face head-on
we have things that we're proud of and
also things that were not proud of and
it's really important especially right
now to consider those things and to move
forward in a positive way it's why the
group chose to open the anthem with a
prelude at a poem by Richard Harrison
good times from your glorious the types
of things no one should have done
our anthem understands words of pride of
notes of mourning we are not that
diverse a group and not by choice of
course but we looked at ourselves and
thought okay well how can we reach out
to engage artists indigenous artists
people of color
and so Calgary R&B singer Justine Tyrell
was asked to take part I know for myself
growing up when I didn't see myself
represented and a lot of things I think
it's consciously disheartening but it's
also subconsciously disheartening but
after seeing swells of support at
marches against racism across the
country Tyrell says she feels a renewed
sense of hope neighbor Canada day I get
excited for the future because I see
this generation in this time just really
owning like what Canada could be giving
the familiar words of Oh Canada new
meaning for the road ahead
[Music]
hether your exbest global news Calgary
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm donor freezin we leave you
tonight with a salute to Alberta's new
leftenant governor her name is Salma
Lakhani she's an immigrant and the first
Muslim person to serve his left-handed
governor anywhere in Canada take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]